on insulte mon père mais moi personne ne
me traitera de sale arabe
alors Mourad
élevé dans le quartier le plus malfamé
de Toulon vous avez fait fortune dans
l'édition de bande dessinée avant de
reprendre le club de rugby de la ville
et de l'amener en finale de la Coupe
d'Europe le 18 mai prochain à Dublin
tout ça à Toulon qu'il n'y a pas si
longtemps été gouverné par le Front
National et puis aujourd'hui le symbole
de la ville est repris par ce que le
Front national n'aimait pas trop à
l'époque à savoir les enfants d'immigrés
[Musique]
Mourad Boudjellal rebonsoir vous êtes né
le 5 juin 1960 à Ollioules petit village
du Var à 7 km de Toulon mais vous passez
vos quatre premières années dans le
quartier Saint-Jean-du-Var à Toulon
votre père conduit des camions poubelles
pour la municipalité et un jour il
décroche un appartement de fonction
c'est rue Bodin dans le quartier le plus
cependant la vie de famille n'est pas
facile votre père à l'alcool mauvais
vous dites les repas étaient une torture
mon père pouvait déraper à tout moment à
cause du vin et ça tombait généralement
sur votre mère des fois c'est explosé et
puis des fois non alors votre grand
frère Farid pourtant atteint de polio
finit par se battre contre votre père un
jour quand même un jour ouais c'est un
truc violent quand même parce que quand
on voit son frère se battre contre son
père c'est et on sait pas on sait pas de
quel côté de quel côté aller quoi et
puis vous vous découvrez la vie d'Arabes
à Toulon les insultes ont été victimes
votre père dans la rue ceci explique
peut-être cela on lui dit ça l'arabe
retourne dans ton pays et lui il répond
moi le voyage connard
il retourne sans problème mais c'est
violent quand on voit son père se faire
insulter quoi voilà et moi je mettais
toujours dit on insulte mon père mais
moi personne ne me traitera de sale
arabe
alors l'école ne vous passionne pas non
et votre seule passion en fait c'est la
bande dessinée à l'âge de 4 ans j'ai
volé mes premières bandes dessinées
parce que quatre ans on a pas beaucoup
de sous le soir au lieu de dormir vous
lisez des bandes dessinées sous les
draps avec une lampe électrique j'avais
une fascination pour le dessin voilà et
j'avais des gamins qui se disent bon moi
je voudrais faire pompier moi je
voudrais faire infirmière et moi depuis
tout petit je vais me disais je préfère
éditeur et d'ailleurs on vous appelez
Mickey vous imaginez dans une famille
d'immigrés et qu'est-ce qu'il veut faire
ton fils et la mère alibab il veut faire
des Mickeys ça passe moins bien
alors à 10 ans vous reliez vos propres
compilations sous la marque Moura
d'édition c'était ma fierté ça est-ce
que j'adorais faire des albums les
albums que moi j'aurais aimé trouver
dans le commerce et donc j'avais appris
à relier des bouquins j'ai découpé des
pages dans des magazines et je faisais
mes propres albums et je marquais mon
roi d'édition et ça me faisait rêver
quoi et là vous lancez dans le commerce
avec des BD que vous achetez aux puces à
6h du matin vous levez à 5h comme disait
l'autre la vie appartient à ceux qui se
lèvent tôt on allait acheter des BD qui
valait beaucoup d'argent mais que les ne
savait pas et que les gens qui se lèvent
plus tard nous achetaient beaucoup plus
cher que ce qu'on les avait acheté le
matin voilà c'était notre petit business
ça ça me plaît
alors vous créez un fanzin au collège
vous dites j'avais beau être minot c'est
moi qui tenais la caisse absolument
j'étais le plus jeune d'avoir 14-15 ans
il y avait de tas de dessinateur en
herbe et c'était moi le patron c'est moi
qui j'irai alors qu'ils avaient au moins
20 ans alors vous avez 14 ans quand
votre père vous amène au festival du
livre à Nice et là vous rencontrez Payot
l'auteur des Schtroumpfs est Tibet
l'auteur de ricochet à 15 ans vous
inaugurez le premier Salon de la BD à
Toulon je pensais que sur la planète
Terre j'étais le seul à aimer la bande
dessinée donc je me suis dit vous avez
vu arriver quand vous avez fait le salon
des tas de gens qui arrivent vous a dit
c'est peut-être pas un mauvais business
c'est peut-être pas mauvais business
mais il y en a des il y a des gens plus
âgés que moi qu'il avait aussi vu à ce
moment-là et qui m'ont dit tu es gentil
mais le festival on va le faire nous
dorénavant effectivement la Maison des
Jeunes et de la Culture de Toulon
s'accaparent le festival et vous écarte
de l'organisation ouais mais je me c'est
pas grave je vais aller le faire
ailleurs et vous allez le faire ailleurs
absolument et je rencontre l'agent à la
culture de la ville de Hyères et
j'arrive à le convaincre j'avais 17 ans
que j'allais déménager mon festival de
Toulon hier et il me dit oui mais ils
vont quand même le faire à Toulon j'ai
mis c'est pas grave on va les tuer on va
faire on va faire un plus beau et plus
grand à 17 ans vous recevez donc Tabary
le créateur 19 good pélos le créateur
des Pieds Nickelés Franquin créateur de
Gaston Lagaffe Maurice créateur de Lucky
Luke et surtout un kibilal qui est quand
même un mec c'est improbable qui venait
pas beaucoup dans les salons
je peux vous dire que c'est fort Alain
Chabat c'était ses débuts qui était un
fou de BD Renault qui est aussi était un
fou de un fou de bande dessinée les
frères Bogdanov qui avait encore une
apparence humaine donc
j'ai 17 ans à l'époque ça j'avais 17 ans
quel démerde [__] alors à 22 ans vous
décidez de lancer votre propre business
et vous créez une boutique de BD qui
s'appelle bédule mais le problème c'est
que j'avais pas un sous pour la monter
la boutique
et ça coûte cher en fond de commerce
alors je rencontre un mec qui avait une
boutique et j'arrive à le convaincre de
pas me vendre le fonds de commerce mais
de me faire un loyer beaucoup plus cher
et il dit oui et là je démarre et voilà
et vous lancez dans l'édition vous
décrochez un prêt de 7500 euros et vous
demandez la grande idée vous demandez à
des auteurs de BD de réaliser une
version sexe disons de leur boulot c'est
une époque où les parodies marchaient
bien les versions un peu cules et de
bandes dessinées
et moi je me suis dit personne ne fera
aussi bien que les auteurs eux-mêmes et
ça super bien marché alors à l'époque
vous voulez donner votre nom de famille
à votre maison d'édition mais avec la
montée du Front national vous préférez
soleil à Boudjellal édition tout le
monde m'a dit ça pourrait te porter
préjudice donc tu as Toulon il fait beau
il y a le soleil donc elle appelle ça
soleil lui dit ok alors c'est plus dur
que vous pensez à un moment vous vous
êtes sur le point de mettre la clé sous
la porte quoi je vous rappelle j'ai le
droit à 400.000 francs de découverte et
j'étais à
3995 je m'en souviens
[Musique]
voilà vous continuez vos rééditions
Tarzan Flash Gordon mais le très gros
coup c'est un truc que vous montez vous
même grâce à l'argent des gens connus
vous lancez des jeunes c'est l'un de
phase de 3 vous savez c'est passé un
truc magique vous avez vendu des
millions d'exemplaires des millions
d'exemplaires dont je sais pas combien
de pays voilà et là le président du RCT
c'est à dire le club de rugby de Toulon
vous propose de reprendre le club alors
là le club étant D2 ça va très très mal
et vous allez y arriver parce que comme
vous avez recruté les meilleurs auteurs
de BD vous allez recruter les meilleurs
joueurs finalement c'est un peu la même
chose alors il y a d'abord Tana oumaga
le capitaine des All Blacks mais ce qui
est chiant dans la vie c'est que il se
passe jamais de choses impossibles il y
a jamais des extraterrestres qui
apparaissent jamais de soucoupe volant
il y a jamais de fantômes tous ces trucs
qu'on voit dans les films on les voit
pas dans la vie ça serait simple et moi
je me suis dit il faudrait que je fasse
un truc impossible dans le rugby et un
truc impossible dans le rugby c'était
faire signer le meilleur joueur du monde
mais oui c'est le cas dans une petite
équipe de deuxième division et donc j'ai
cette relation avec tanaho-maga mais
comme se passe on communique par mail je
m'aime je n'ai même pas au téléphone et
à chaque mail on se dit au prochain mail
il va dire non et puis ça avance ça
avance et un jour je reçois un coup de
fil un mec il me dit je suis l'agent
français de Tana Oméga est-ce qu'on peut
se rencontrer pour parler de sa venue à
Toulon et ce jour-là le Top 14 va
devenir le premier championnat du monde
puisque ça va changer toute la
philosophie des présidents de club
toutes les stars de la planète vont
venir en France dans le Top 14 de ce
petit transfert de Tanah Omaha que je
voulais parce que ça me semblait magique
c'était comme voir apparaître les
extraterrestres là où m'a dit alors
après il y aura Johnny Wilkinson
Frédéric Michalak Bryan Habana enfin
voilà quoi vous faites de Toulon un club
super intéressant c'est un club de stars
comme on dit mais c'est aussi un club
qui a une âme moi c'est c'est ma
conception de faire venir des gens qui
viennent de différents côtés de la
planète et je dis toujours que on a plus
d'affinités avec quelqu'un qui est né à
10000 km mais avec qui on va partager
les mêmes joueurs les mêmes émotions
pendant un temps que quelqu'un qui est
votre voisin et que vous rencontrerez
jamais parce qu'il vous intéresse pas
c'est pour ça que la notion de pays tout
ça mais assez indifférent
alors résultat le 18 mai prochain final
de la Coupe d'Europe Dublin contre l'ASM
Clermont donc là il y a que des Français
finalement on est les meilleurs en rugby
c'est normal alors bien sûr votre
franc-parlet ne fait pas toujours la
faire des barons de l'Ovalie en janvier
2012 après un match perdu contre
Clermont vous parlez de sodomie
arbitrale c'était une petite sodomie en
plus donc
j'étais très choqué pour des mots de
passer en commission de discipline parce
que les commissions de discipline c'est
fait pour des actes pour des violences
mais quand les commissions de discipline
se réunissent pour des mots ça veut dire
que ce sont des commissions de
disciplines morales on trouve ça
dangereux quoi vous avez pris combien
100 jours de 130 jours si vous avez de
la culture cinématographique littéraire
Monroe 1120 pour sodomise vous avez dit
on pourra revoir les images pas sur
Youtube mais sur YouPorn
l'action qui nous a éliminé en
demi-finale il y a trois ou quatre ans
c'est vrai qu'elle est elle mérite
d'être souillé ou pas alors aujourd'hui
vous avez vendu les éditions du soleil
pour vous consacrer 100 tout le long
tout va bien pour l'instant ça va oui
mais enfin la seule souffrance ça reste
le racisme pour sauver beaucoup de
lettres anonyme énormément traite de
pourriture bougnoulesques j'ai tout reçu
quand je suis passé en commission
discipline on a reçu une très bien qui
me disait
quand tu sortiras de la commission
discipline tu pourras toujours aller
brûler les voitures c'est dans tes gènes
voilà ce genre de choses voilà j'en
reçois plein ou connard quand même oui
je reçois trois ou quatre par mois
mais des trucs très très insultants
genre les ça va les seuls les seuls
[__] sans les [__] qui sont
morts on aura ta peau
en menace de mort si tu aimes pas la
France tu la quittes donc encore toute
une partie c'est encore le racisme le
dire en même temps à Toulon vous
cherchez hein parce que c'est quand même
la capitale ce qui est rassurant quand
même ce sont des gens qui qui se
prétendent français et donc pour être
français il faut quand même avoir un
minimum de culture française et qui font
beaucoup de fautes d'orthographe
bravo merci mon Rabus général je
rappelle le titre de votre livre ma
mauvaise réputation
s'est édité aux éditions La Martinière
merci de votre témoignage génial si j'ai
bien tout suivi ton papa est ramassé les
poubelles c'est ça non il avait le droit
à peu près de conduire le camion c'était
la promotion à Montpellier on a
ramasseur de poubelles très connu qui a
été Nicolas qui a été champion de France
donc merci beaucoup merci Rémi et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de inarritube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu